this vibrant cape and shawl are the
largest pieces of cloth to ever be made
from spider silk over the course of
three years it took a team of about 100
people in the highlands of madagascar to
collect the silk spin the threads weave
the fibers and embroider the details
in the end 1.2 million golden orb weaver
spiders each producing 30 to 50 meters
of yellow thread were used to create
this masterpiece before being released
back into the wild
but why would anyone go to this amount
of trouble to make something out of such
a strange and difficult to obtain
material because spider silk has what
seems to be almost magical properties
for thousands of years humans have been
fascinated by this material
the ancient greeks used cobwebs to treat
wounds
and traditional hunters in the south
pacific use spider silk to catch fish
where the spider silk fibers get stuck
in the fish's serrated teeth and they
are unable to tear through due to the
silk's strength
to be able to withstand impact forces
from flying insects without breaking
spider silk has evolved to be incredibly
flexible even more flexible than
man-made nylon it's bio-compatible and
bio-degradable and on a per weight basis
spider silk is even stronger than steel
and now spider silk is attracting the
attention of geneticists biochemists and
material scientists who are working to
unravel the mystery of its incredible
properties
what is it about spider silk that makes
it so flexible so durable and so strong
just how strong is it and will we ever
be able to harness this power for
ourselves
for spiders making such a material is
just part of their biology
the earliest known proto-spider lived
about 380 million years ago during the
devonian period
and were among the first creatures to
live on land
this spider had the classic thin waist
and abdominal segmentation of the modern
spider these early spiders also had
spinnerets which is the organ that
produces silk
however their spinnerets were located in
the middle of the abdomen instead of at
the end of the abdomen like in modern
spiders
this means that instead of weaving webs
they most likely use their silk in
sheets to cover their eggs or line their
burrows
it wasn't until about 250 million years
ago that spiders with spinnerets at the
end of their abdomen appeared allowing
for more elaborate silk creations
not all spiders are able to make
intricately patterned webs like these
but the ones that can do so masterfully
of the 45 000 or so species of spiders
about 12
500 species are orb weavers
the builders of the spiral wheel-shaped
webs often found in gardens fields and
forests
the creation of the silk begins in the
spider's silk glands and the spinnerets
located on the posterior end of their
abdomen inside the glands the silk
starts out as liquid as it travels down
the cavity to the spigots a combination
of water extraction acid and tension
turns it into its final solid silk form
this silk then travels through the
spinnerets where it's spun into a fiber
orb weavers produce at least seven
different kinds of silk silt from the
major ampalate is the structural silk
like the bridge line and the radial
spokes
then there's silk from the flagella form
gland which makes the spiral then
there's the aggregate silk which creates
the sticky balls which capture prey
but of the many types the most
extensively studied is dragline silk aka
the spider's lifeline dragline silk
enables the spider to hang from ceilings
and serves as a constant connection to
the web allowing it to drop away if it's
in danger
and this particular silk is perhaps the
most remarkable material from the
natural world when it comes to its
strength many comparisons are made
between spider silk and steel and for
good reason dragline silk combines
toughness strength and elasticity to an
extraordinary degree it's a composite
material composed of two different
proteins spy join one and spy join two
each protein contains an amorphous
non-crystalline matrix this is the
stretchable part of the silk that gives
it its elasticity then embedded in the
amorphous portions are crystalline
regions that link together and toughen
the silk
it's certainly an impressive material
but do the steel comparisons really hold
up can this delicate natural material
really have a similar strength to the
material we build bridges and
skyscrapers out of
to get to the bottom of this claim we
first need to understand what the
meaning of the word strength even is
there are different types of material
properties that define how a material
will respond to different types of
stress
there's things like toughness a
material's ability to resist damage from
impacts
glass for example has low toughness and
shatters when smashed with a hammer
rubber on the other hand can completely
withstand a similar blow
then there's compressive strength the
ability to withstand being pushed
together before being compressed crushed
or buckling and stiffness a material's
ability to resist being deformed
for properties like stiffness spider
silk is nowhere close to steel
but there is one area where spider silk
particularly excels in its tensile
strength the resistance to breaking
under tension
tensile strength is measured in pascals
the pressure of one newton per square
meter and for a material that seems
rather delicate it surprisingly has a
similar or sometimes even better tensile
strength than steel
there are many different types of steel
and thus tensile strength of steel can
wildly vary up to 2.5 gigapascals for
certain specialized steel composites but
let's look at the most common type of
steel used in construction
mild steel or plain carbon steel
on average mild steel has a tensile
strength of 0.4 gigapascals
and while spider silk's tensile strength
can also vary one of the strongest
spider silks comes from the golden orb
spider which has a tensile strength of
up to 1.6 gigapascals
when measuring tensile strength the
diameter of the material is accounted
for which means a hair-like strand a
pencil width strand or a thick beam of
the same material will have the exact
same tensile strength this means a
single strand of spider silk can
outperform many types of steel of the
same diameter this is impressive enough
but when you consider the densities of
each material it's even more so
spider silk is about 1 6 as dense as
steel
this means a strand of silk is much
stronger for its weight than steel is
another area where spider silk excels is
its ductility its ability to be
stretched and deformed without breaking
therefore its toughness the area under
the stress strain curve is remarkably
high
higher than even kevlar
and for spiders this level of strength
and flexibility is essential to their
survival when an insect strikes their
web the stretching of the matrix enables
the web to withstand the impact of the
flying prey
over hundreds of millions of years these
properties were favored during the
process of natural selection giving us
the extraordinary material we know today
its potential uses in textiles medicine
and even aviation are boundless
and so it's no surprise that now
scientists are working tirelessly to
recreate it
if spider silk is so incredible why
don't we have ropes cables parachutes or
nets made from this super strong super
lightweight material
because the mass production of spider
silk is incredibly challenging
trying to farm them at scale has been
attempted and proven to be basically
impossible
spiders are carnivorous animals that
don't like to live in groups as it
results in large-scale cannibalism but
collecting milking and then releasing
wild spiders is also a huge challenge
collecting the amount of silk needed to
make anything of significance takes a
very long time such as the 3 years it
took to make one cape and shawl
so for these reasons scientists are
looking to recreate it themselves one
common method is to genetically modify a
different host organism to produce
spider silk proteins
this is a great idea but historically
there has been one major problem with
recreating spider silk it has been very
difficult to find a way to produce large
enough proteins and large proteins are
important the tensile strength and
toughness of spider silk are positively
correlated with its molecular weight the
bigger the molecule the stronger the
silk so because of this scientists
turned to plants plants already have the
genetic capacity to make large proteins
and since agriculture is easy to scale
up silk in theory could be produced and
harvested in mass quantities however the
proteins plants make are not as large as
what spiders produce meaning the silks
spun from them will have a less
repetitive protein structure and won't
be as high quality
so scientists set their sights on a
different host
something that can easily create high
amounts of spider silk but is perhaps a
bit unexpected
goats domesticated mammals already
naturally produce large volumes of
protein-rich milk
by targeting the gene for milk protein
genetically modified spider goats can
produce spider silk proteins in their
milk
first attempts at this method were
promising the milk contained significant
quantities of spider silk proteins
however the size of the proteins was
still too small
just 65 kilodaltons compared to spider
silks 350.
so scientists turned to silkworms they
offer a great advantage since they
already have the necessary spinning
apparatus needed to turn silk proteins
into silk inefficient artificial
spinning methods aren't needed
studies have found that modified
silkworms can produce large amounts of
spider silk with their resulting silk
content consisting of 35 spider silk
protein
but spider silk made from modified silk
worms isn't perfect
the protein is still smaller than
natural spider silk proteins resulting
in mechanical properties that fall
behind natural spider silk
but perhaps the most promising method
yet a method capable of making the
biggest proteins comes from something
much smaller genetically modified
bacteria can be used to create large
amounts of a desired protein because the
bacteria e coli replicates itself pretty
quickly a large modified colony could be
made in no time however e coli 2 has
some limitations
this small bacteria did not evolve to
make proteins as large as spider silk
proteins
in spiders the genetic sequence that
codes for long chains of proteins has
many repeating sections the more
repetitions of the sequence the bigger
the resulting protein so using that
logic researchers inserted a similarly
long repeating sequence into their
bacterial host
but there's one problem
after the dna sequence reaches a certain
size the bacteria can't handle it they
chop the sequence into smaller pieces so
that the resulting protein doesn't get
too large but in 2018 scientists found a
workaround they added a short genetic
sequence to the silk dna that promotes a
chemical reaction between the resulting
proteins fusing them together to form a
bigger protein
this method was so effective that the
resulting proteins were larger than
anyone's ever been able to make
in fact they were larger than most
natural spider proteins at
556 kilodaltons
once the proteins are collected they can
be spun into fibers with properties
similar to natural spider silk but the
process still has some drawbacks
mostly that the spinning process is hard
to replicate
the transformation from a liquid state
inside the silk glands to a solid state
outside of the spigots is pretty
complicated but scientists have figured
out that a sudden drop in ph a
particular salt concentration and sheer
forces allow the spider silk to
materialize by mimicking these
conditions scientists are getting close
to an artificial spinning process that's
as good as the real thing
so far every group that's attempted to
produce enough spider silk to bring it
to the mass market has failed but with
these recent advances spider silk may
very well soon replace petroleum-based
synthetic fibers used in many industries
in 2016 am silk collaborated with adidas
to develop a concept sneaker and omega
recently created a special edition
spider silk watch strap
airbus is also exploring how it can be
used in aviation it soon could take on a
role much like carbon fiber in today's
world it's one of the best examples of
innovation inspired by nature by looking
closely at nature's best ideas we start
to see that the answers to our toughest
problems are all around us
spiders are not exactly everyone's
favorite animal which is understandable
but it's easy to put aside the
heebie-jeebie factor when you think of
their remarkable evolution and their
place in the intricate web of life
spiders ants termites these bugs that we
may overlook or downright despise are
actually some of nature's best engineers
researchers are looking to termites now
for example to understand how they build
massive structures using a process
called biocementation where grains of
soil are fused together into small balls
with moisture saliva and excretion
basically a process of construction
using their own type of bricks these
structures also maintain a constant
temperature and humidity inside while
still ventilating the underground nests
it's an absolute wonder of nature
and human engineers are now trying to
replicate this type of architecture
to see firsthand how the termites build
their mounds and to understand the
surprising difficulty with studying
these insects you should watch termites
the inner sanctum on curiosity stream
it's a 45 minute in-depth film that
takes you from borneo to africa to
inside the deepest hardest to reach
chambers of their nests
it's one of many detailed and beautiful
nature films on curiosity stream that
will teach you about a corner of
evolution that you might not have
considered before
alone curiosity stream is a fantastic
educational streaming platform
but now curiosity stream has partnered
with us to offer an even better package
by signing up to curiositystream you now
also get a subscription to nebula nebula
is a streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators it's a place where we
can upload our videos ad free and a
place where we can experiment with new
original content we have so much new
exclusive content planned for nebula in
the new year like a real science series
on human evolution and real
engineering's upcoming new series the
battle of britain
and right now the bundle deal is at a
hugely discounted price
for just 11 59 you get access to both
curiosity stream and nebula for the
entire year that's 42
off the usual price and means you're
getting both services for less than a
dollar per month this deal will only
last for a few more days so don't
hesitate for too long signing up is also
the single best way you can support this
channel it helps us to keep growing and
helps us to bring you more and more new
content
so go to
curiositystream.com real science to get
in on this incredible deal
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video the insane biology of the
orca or watch real engineering's latest
video about the insane engineering of
the james webb telescope